هم القرار شبه قضائي في
لهجته
لكنهم لم يقرروا ما إذا
كان يجب إعادة دونالد ترامب أم لا ،
لماذا لم يعيدوه إلى منصبه خلال
هذه
الأشهر الستة من صنع السياسات.
ريتشارد أه
يتحمل مسؤولية اتخاذ القرار هنا.
لديهم قواعد أه قاموا بتفسيرها
بطريقة وجد المجلس
أنها غير صحيحة ، لقد أخبرنا فيسبوك
بوضوح شديد في الأشهر الستة المقبلة أنهم
بحاجة إلى العودة وتطبيق عقوبة
على السيد ترامب تتفق مع
قواعدهم والتعليق إلى أجل غير مسمى
ليس شيئًا تدعمه
قواعدهم إنه شيء ليس
له معايير واضحة
أه عند فرضه أو رفعه
وهذه بالكامل لتقدير فيسبوك
وهذا غير مقبول من وجهة نظر مجلس الإدارة
أه لأننا نتطلع
للدفاع عن حرية
التعبير للجمهور عن وجهة نظر vox الشعبية
حول
ما فعلته اللوحة هو أنك
تضغط عليه مرة أخرى
إلى Facebook ، وقد أتيحت لك الفرصة للقول إلى
أجل غير مسمى  يحظر نعم ، حظر لأجل غير مسمى ، لم يكن هناك
لاعبون سياسيون ، لكنك لم تكن
كذلك ، تم طرح سؤال على مجلس الإدارة
وهو
تعليق Facebook لأجل غير مسمى
مناسب ، لقد أخبرناهم بوضوح أنه
ليس Facebook يتحمل مسؤولية التصرف
هنا بشكل صحيح
، لا يمكنهم ببساطة إلغاء التحميل
مشاكلهم الصعبة لمجلس الإدارة أو أي شخص آخر
ولكن كشركة تضع القواعد
وتبني
التكنولوجيا ، تقع على عاتقهم مسؤولية التصرف أولاً
والتصرف بسرعة لقد أخبرناهم
بالعودة واتخاذ قرار آخر
الآن في هذه الحالة قلنا  عندها فقط
، فهل من غير المناسب
أن يكون هناك حظر غير محدد
إذا كان هذا هو الحال ، وبالتالي فإن
الطبيعة غير المحددة للحظر غير مناسبة ،
فلن يكون من
الصحيح إعادة السيد ترامب
بينما يتم اتخاذ قرار نهائي بشأن القضية الأوسع
بشكل جميل  إلى حد كبير بالطريقة
التي تقوم بها العديد من محاكم الاستئناف
بإطلاق سراح شخص ما بانتظار
قرارهم النهائي
أه ليس في هذه الحالة لا لذلك وجد المجلس
أيضًا بوضوح شديد أن دونا  لترامب أه
استحق الإيقاف في السابع من يناير
شجع الرئيس وشرع
العنف الذي كلف الأرواح في واشنطن
أه قال مجلس الإدارة لـ facebook
قبل إعادة
أي مستخدم مؤثر بما في ذلك
القادة السياسيين ورؤساء الدول
تحتاج إلى اختبار ما إذا كان هذا
القرار مرجحًا  لإلحاق الضرر بالمستخدمين ،
لذلك طلبنا من facebook في الأشهر الستة
المقبلة العودة واختبار ذلك
قبل اتخاذ أي إجراء
لاستعادة الرئيس